[Musique]
bonjour à tous on se retrouve pour un
nouveau numéro du 7 8 dossiers ce mois
ci la rédaction de tv 60,18 vous propose
une émission consacrée à la culture
urbaine
c'est parti petite anna k souhaite
devenir grand c'est pourquoi s'obstine à
jouer des sauvages dès l'âge de 10 ans
devenir adulte avec des impôts comme on
l'entend dans les yvelines cette culture
s'est développée notamment dans les
zones urbaines à travers différentes
activités du street art à la danse hip
hop en passant par la musique comme vous
venez de l'entendre mais pour commencer
je vous propose de découvrir les
yamakasi des clayes-sous-bois ils
réalisent des figures à partir des
structures urbaines
en hiver ils s'entraînent dans un
gymnase mickeal et demi d'euros et
grégory canal et sont allés les
rencontrer
[Musique]
souvenez vous c'était en 2001 les
français découvrent les yamakasi des
acrobates de rue qui défient la gravité
[Musique]
aujourd'hui les figures pratiqué dans le
film ce sont transposés dans la vie
réelle aux clayes-sous-bois une section
parcours a vu le jour en 2011 pour
répondre à la demande
ici la pratique de ce sport urbain
rebaptisé fristel gym se passe en
intérieur dans un gymnase une chute pour
vous être fatal quand même parce que
vous maîtrisez pas 100% de la figure je
leur ai proposé d'apprendre en toute
sécurité
des figures acrobatiques et dès lors que
la figure est à est acquise en intérieur
maintenant on peut le faire à
l'extérieur il y aura un goût beaucoup
moins d'accidents depuis la création de
cette section la pratique de cette
discipline connaît un franc succès au
club
le nombre de licenciés est passé de cinq
adhérents la première année à une
quarantaine de pratiquants venus de
toutes les yvelines pour cette saison
2010 8
c'est notre corps c'est pas un vélo
c'est pas en équipement c'est vraiment
notre corps c'est une option chutes sont
faute d'accord si on doit être très
rigoureux on est très libre on apprend
vraiment de on est capable une grosse
adrénaline
quand on lance la figure il ya une
montée d'adrénaline et dès qu'on la
rentrée on pas en 100 euros clairement
une fois les bases maîtriser pour nancy
cour le 3 heures le vendredi c'était de
brûler dépasse les frontières du gymnase
gimme pour pratiquer ce sport dans son
lieu de naissance la rue les pratiquants
un peu les traceurs utilise le milieu
urbain et la nature pour réaliser des
figures
[Musique]
on n'est pas vraiment des casse croûte
pour ça que les gens partent en ont peur
dans la rue c'est qu'il pense qu'on se
lance comme ça et que si on se rate
c'est notre hôte mais on passe beaucoup
de temps on sait on sait de quoi on est
capable on fait quand même beaucoup de
repérage avant de se lancer
et c'est une phase très importante parce
que sinon
la peur prend le dessus et lancement en
danger alors qu'on aurait peut-être été
capable de le faire son sac on fait très
attention avant de se lancer pour
l'importer mouvement smc des
clayes-sous-bois espère désormais
atteindre une centaine d'adhérents dans
les prochaines années la structure
pourrait surfer sur la dynamique de ce
sport qui vient d'être inscrite
officiellement dans la fédération
française de gymnastique
[Musique]
la bombe de peinture et un mur dans un
lieu abandonné api grave depuis près de
15 ans le mur un terrain de jeu pour ce
jeune l'yvelinois n'est pas seulement
comment le truc ça se voit ici à plein
de plein de black book machine j'ai
retrouvé total a en fait se sceller des
choses que j'ai retrouvé qu'ils sont les
laits je crois que c'est mon tout
premier ce qu'on appelle un black book
en fait tiendra bouquin auquel vous êtes
des lettrages tout commence ici à benne
dans la maison familiale
le street art tapis pierre antoine
ménard de son vrai nom le découvre par
son grand frère et la révélation un mur
et une photo en souvenir une passion qui
le fait ensuite travaillé en atelier
quand elles revenues de leur venue d'un
grand voyage qu'il est parti sur
barcelone
je crois dans des années 2000 quelque
chose comme ça et en fait il a monté une
boutique de ce prêt et moi je suis allé
lui rendre visite en vacances je vais
avoir 15 16 ans et j'ai découvert à
barcelone toute une équipe qui est
devenu mon collectif plus tard après je
suis revenu ici en banlieue parisienne
et après plus tard sur paris et là j'ai
découvert le graffiti le vrai graffitis
les tunnels du métro tout ça va et après
après ses noces est un peu c'est un peu
comme une drogue
quand on est piqué ben devient un lieu
de stockage 15 ans de travail et plus
d'une centaine d'oeuvres réalisées
aujourd'hui ils créent ils recherchent
ils dessinent à bobigny mêlant culture
des années 80 aux références classiques
la bombe n'est plus seul outil j'essaie
de donner une consistance de deux murs
un peu haut
avec toile coûtera avec de l'acrylique
de la peinture de chantiers beaucoup de
beaucoup de deux techniques populaire en
fait j'utilise un produit qu un espèce
de latex aussi pour superposer des
couches de couleurs et venir gratter que
les couches d'eau soit par s ce prêt de
la pastel grâce beaucoup d'encre voilà
un peu un peu tout ce que je trouve
longtemps considérées comme marginales
dégradants et illégale
le street art investit aujourd'hui les
galeries api vit de son art vente de
toiles et expositions comme ici à la
celle saint cloud avec le collectif 1980
là l'intelligence en fait avec finesse
d'amener l'histoire de l'art dans le
street art donc y rattachent un peu les
choses dans le collectif il ya plusieurs
artistes qui ont fait les beaux-arts lui
n'a pas fait les beaux-arts mais là ils
puissent vraiment son énergie là donnant
même s'il explose api n'a pas abandonné
le graffiti et la rue alors ouvrez bien
les yeux pour découvrir les trois
lettres de sa signature
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le rythme dans la peau
ces élèves perfectionnent leurs
chorégraphies à peine âgée de 8 ans est
déjà en plein apprentissage du hip hop
tu peux m'expliquer ce que tu as fait
aujourd'hui par la danse les
échauffements et les abdominaux
j'aimais bien danser
et c'est ma copine signa m'avait donné
envie d'essayer une envie venus par le
bouche à oreille mais si le hip hop est
aujourd'hui considérée comme une danse
comme les autres elle n'a pas toujours
profité d'une bonne réputation
et
[Musique]
né dans les années 70 dans le bronx
quartier connu new york pour ces gangs
et ses trafics de drogue
la culture hip hop se développe dans les
années 80 90 des artistes comme haïti ou
ndbl des favoris son ouverture mais
véhicule une image de landes professeur
depuis 15 ans au sein de l'association
illicites dance
adeline a noté une véritable évolution
dans les mentalités
je pense qu'il ya eu un phénomène de
mode aussi je pense que les émissions
aussi comme les star académie ce genre
de choses qui ont ouvert la danse tout
simplement la danse au terme large
les gens ont découvert un petit peu plus
la danse et le hip hop qui était quand
même un milieu très fermé à l'époque
très sains de rue enfin c'était vraiment
une danse de rue qui aujourd'hui est
devenu vraiment un style très moderne
c'est la danse actuelle du moment cet
engouement favorise aussi la diversité
culturelle
malgré l'aspect agressif souvent mise en
avant le mouvement hip hop se veut une
culture de respect et de mixité sociale
vous avez vu les les les petites têtes
de denges que j'ai dans mon cours qui
viennent faire du hip hop
donc ça c'est juste génial en fait c'est
plus c'est pu réserver 1
[Musique]
à
à une tranche sociale en fait c'est plus
à l'époque comme on disait c'est ce
qu'est pas trop les moyens qui faisait
ça un peu tout seul de leur côté
aujourd'hui non c'est vraiment ouvert à
tout le monde
un style que chacun peut pratiquer à une
seule condition c'est un conseil pour
être bon il comptait pour connaître les
pas pour est très sûr la musique pour
tous
[Musique]
faire penser en faisant danser c'est
l'esprit des compositions dabou cet
artiste et binoy de 42 ans originaire de
trappes prépare son prochain album
afri pop spirit dans son studio il
travaille sur un morceau en particulier
bamako boss
[Musique]
après avoir composé la musique et écrit
son texte à bout peut commencer à
enregistrer
c'est le troisième couplet de la chanson
et c'est parti dans la cabine si la
goutte applique à jeter c'est peut-être
que toi même tu a fauté non faut pas
fait ça tapait la doudou sinon le dieu
peu de beauté en réalité légaux ce sont
les boss
si tu as le doute montre moi comment tu
peux à coucher grâce à son studio 223
abou peu procédé au mixage
place ensuite à la première écoute et
donc là je vous faire écouter donc après
le travail justement de mx qu'est ce que
cela donne avant le mastering ses
tonalités ses textes sa rythmique
caractérise son style la fripe hop un
genre musical développé depuis 2001
en 2007 il sort son premier ep le
nouveau souffle de la fri pop en 2010
son premier album à free pop color avec
un slogan une musique qui tu ressembles
rassemble et à rien ne ressemble sachant
que l'idée c'est vraiment essayé de
rassembler les personnes qu rassembler
les peuples rassembler les personnes
surtout qu'ils ont au delà de sa couleur
de peau sa classe sociale est ta
religion c'est en fait une couleur
d'esprit qui nous rassemble avec des
valeurs c'est vraiment un mélange entre
la world music et la musique urbaine à
savoir que moins chantant fait en
français et en bambara qui est une
langue du mali sur des beats parfois que
son hip hop d'autres un peu plus sale ça
donc c'est vraiment un mélange entre eux
world music et musiques urbaines à bout
peut s'inspirer de rythme à partir d'une
musique pour ensuite ajouté sa patte
a berné elle ne renvoie nos rangs 12e
sauver la vie des pauvres moi dans mon
labo à pourra faire un petit peu tout
est ensuite envoyé ce que moi j'ai envie
de faire entendre de ma propre création
sans que quelqu'un il ya rajouté quoi
que ce soit qui dénature un peu ce que
j'ai envie de vous présenter la fripe up
c'est aussi aider des jeunes à
développer leur projet musical ce soir à
bourg soit six tirs rappeur d'elancourt
le travail va durer une partie de la
soirée
merci de nous avoir suivis si vous
souhaitez revoir cette émission en
replay rendez vous sur le site internet
télé 78 ou sur notre application mobile
on se retrouve le mois prochain au salon
de l'agriculture pour l'ouverture d'un
nouveau dossier
[Musique]